all right let's get caught up about a
number of goings-on in the american
political world hillary clinton is never
running for president again this is what
she is now saying and this is
interesting because there has been
increasing speculation not only from
some on the left who are uh sort of uh
skeptical of the establishment
democratic party but also for many on
the right who seem convinced that at
some point hillary clinton will return
and 2024 will be a rematch between trump
and clinton uh hillary clinton is now
very directly saying she is not running
for president again she was interviewed
by nora o'donnell she was asked the
question directly and then maybe more
interestingly she was asked well then
what about if trump runs in 2024
let's take a look at this this is pretty
interesting hillary clinton is on a new
campaign of sorts with her daughter
chelsea for a new apple tv plus
docu-series highlighting extraordinary
women it's called gutsy we sat down
exclusively with the former secretary
and asked her what's next
would you ever run for president again
no
no but i'm going to do everything i can
to make sure that
we have a president who respects our
democracy and the rule of law and
upholds our institutions what if donald
trump runs again
he should be soundly defeated it should
start in the republican party grow a
backbone stand up to this guy and heaven
forbid if he gets the nomination he
needs to be defeated roundly and sent
back to mar-a-lago the florida mansion
now in the spotlight after an fbi
so she's being very clear here she's not
running for president again now those
who are committed to the idea of some
conspiracy to install hillary clinton or
whatever they will say that she still
might run but
i believe her it seems very clear that
she isn't running and i think that this
is correct i don't think that she should
run again she would have been a better
president than trump i voted for her but
i believe that the window has passed and
i think it's the same thing with bernie
sanders quite frankly even though i know
there are many in my audience who don't
like it when i say that and when i say
this i am not speaking
you know
i i want to remind everybody one of the
ways in which
i hope the left is different from the
right
is that we don't deify candidates
trump often will say i don't know that
joe biden has anybody running around
with a biden hat or a biden shirt or
whatever
yeah because on the left my desire is
that we see elected officials just as
people with whom we hopefully agree on
more than we disagree
and we vote for them and then we move on
with our lives in other words the right
has these cults of personality sometimes
the left does too
and sometimes when i say i think
bernie's time has passed
people will get very angry as with me
because they see bernie almost as as a
sort of deity i voted for bernie in the
primary and hillary ended up being the
nominee i voted for hillary in the
general but she lost i would vote for
either of them over trump or desantis or
whoever
but i think both of them
despite me voting for them
are now beyond running for president and
i mean listen maybe hillary should run
for special master and could review
those documents no i'm kidding but i
believe this is the right decision i
believe it is really you know it's been
said for a while now
really since obama it's i guess over a
while six years it's been said for a
period of time now that overall the
democratic party needs to look younger
in its ranks for presidential candidates
i think that hillary recognizes that i
think bernie recognizes as well i don't
think either is going to run for the
democratic nomination in 2024 and there
really are lots of good people around
and i've talked about many of them and i
would like to see some some other new
people run and we'll have plenty of time
to talk about that
one of our sponsors today is feels feels
is a premium cbd designed to help you
feel your best delivered right to your
door with everything going on in our
daily lives we all need to take a moment
to relax and that's where feels comes in
many people report cbd helping with
anxiety stress and sleeplessness if you
have aches or pains there are people who
use cbd as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels cbd oil is awesome the cbd infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about cbd dosage finding the right
starting point and when you join the
feels monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today and get fifty percent off your
first order with free shipping when you
go to feels.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below